mein thema heute abend frankreichs
präsident marco hat die pandemie für
beendet erklärt vive la france in
frankreich gilt kaum noch eine krone
regel mit dem virus leben das ist die
maxime dort vor ort wer in diesen tagen
also von deutschland nach frankreich in
dem zug fährt der wird ein denkwürdiges
spiel erleben denn bis zur grenze was
wir auf in frankreich dann was geweckt
man fragt sich ja schon ob es in
frankreich einen anderen corona virus
gibt als in deutschland
also es aber eigentlich nicht der fall
die franzosen haben sich nur einfach
dazu entschieden mit ihm zu leben es
gibt noch die empfehlung das sind groß
und schulgebäuden belüftet wird aber
ansonsten lebt es sich in frankreich vor
der pandemie und was besonders schön ist
was mich besonders freut die experten
zeigen anders erzählt zu lande wo wir
panik lauter bereits gewesen ist haben
einsicht als experten gerade aufgelöst
wurde fand sein langjähriger
vorsitzender der immer nur monologe der
presse kritische worte über die politik
zitat natürlich bedauere ich vieles
sagte er in einem radiointerview wir
haben manchmal die gesundheit über die
menschlichkeit gestellt einige bewohner
von altenheimen und lebenswillen
verloren und nur noch auf den tod
gewartet weil sie angehören nicht mehr
sehen das hatten wir auch hier in diesem
land in deutschland aber von dieser
einsicht kann man hierzulande nur
träumen
was mich brennend interessieren würde
ist jetzt natürlich die frage ein herz
kreislauf waren es keine chorherr
maßnahmen ergeben wird
ja das soll es ja politiker geben die
daten nennen und max stadler nach seiner
eingefahren werden damit ich denke wir
werden sehen wie sich der winter und
herbst entwickelt und ob die maßnahmen
die jetzt im infektionsschutzgesetz
geregelt wurden überhaupt anwendung
finden werden denn es ist ja einfach nur
das eine fürsorge oder vorsorge
getroffen wurde mit diesem gesetz und
noch keine anwendung beschlossen dh die
länder haben die möglichkeit diese
regeln anzuwenden sollten kritische
situation entstehen warum machen wir das
so früh weil wir ein anderes system
haben als frankreich zum beispiel jede
grundrechts einschränkungen mussten der
bundesrepublik deutschland durch das
parlament gehen was auch richtig ist und
was auch gut so sonst ein leeres unserer
geschichte dass wir dies auch so tun in
anderen ländern kann das mit dem
präsidialerlass sofort gemacht werden
das heißt wir haben
wir haben immer einen vorlauf bei
solchen sachen das heißt ich muss eine
vorsorge tragen sonst bin ich einfach
nicht verantwortungsvoll meiner rolle
als politiker so und diesem baukasten
haben wir gepackt ich denke er ist nicht
übervoll sondern eher so dass maßnahmen
drin sind die zu einer eindämmung
geeignet sein können aber jetzt müssen
wir erst einmal schauen unter welchen
voraussetzungen werden diese von den
ländern aufgerufen und da werden wir
ganz genau hingucken denn grundrechts
einschränkungen ist immer die ultima
ratio in einer demokratie und da werden
auch wir als freie demokraten ganz genau
schauen wie es in welchem land wir
sehen das ganze dilemma der ampel
regierung die muss eine
freiheitsliebende partei und ich denke
mal fresse besteht genauso für diese
richtung auch obwohl hier ein bisschen
was anderes verkündet mit einer staats
dirigistischen und einer staatsgläubigen
partei zusammenarbeiten um irgendwie die
menschen zu
mitzuteilen dass das was sie tun richtig
ist ist es aber nicht denn wir sehen es
in vielen anderen ländern auch dass die
möglichkeiten zurück gegeben werden an
die bürger eigentlich ein und
bürgerinnen und bürger eigentlich eine
forderung der fdp warum kann man den
menschen nicht sagen leute ihr seid alt
genug mittlerweile auch kenntnisreich
genug euch zu schützen wer maske tragen
will soll sie tragen in der bahn und im
flieger so wie das in frankreich der
fall ist wer nicht wird auch nicht
diskriminiert sondern er soll sich
ebenso dar einsetzen mittlerweile sind
wir doch so weit dass wir eben
entsprechend auch handeln und agieren
können und dieses dieses dieses zu
vertrauen kann ich doch mittlerweile im
dritten jahr von gruner die menschen ab
verlangen und auch gewähren anstatt sie
weiter zu dirigieren und die
verantwortlichkeiten zu verschieben in
die länder wo es natürlich unterschiede
gibt da gibt es den einen der sagt ja
mache ich doch ein bisschen stärker
staatsdirigismus der andere sagt naja
schauen wir erstmal was passiert so wird
es doch kommen der leidtragende werden
die bürgerinnen und bürger sein und
nicht die politiker die sich dann wir
haben es gesehen irgendwo nach kanada
zwölf stunden lang mit maske fliegen
lassen und eben nicht die maske trägt ja
aber sie werden kann lockt uns mehr
haben es wird keiner macht bei uns geben
die gibt es in diesen instrumenten
kassen
frankreich keine locker ins meer es geht
nicht um dankbarkeit es geht darum dass
man überlebt hat welche maßnahmen können
hilfreich sein
er erklärt
ich erzähle ich kann auch andere länder
an der weilheimer krohn und ich so
machen kann und mit einer präsidialen
verordnung das ganze thema ein
verriegelt in deutschland haben wir den
deutschen bundestag ein gesetz das muss
ein gesetz ändern muss mit dem gesetz
verfahren sehr gut
wunderbar ohne maske alles machen
während man sich noch tragen musste
jetzt jetzt nicht so als wäre man froh
in frankreich hat ein karl lauterbach
das ist doch das entscheidende frage hat
keine panik minister comedian und war
auch noch so alles ist das war nur ein
auge translator sonntag sollte machen da
das gelände ab auftritt amazon
anwendungen her ist halt einfach so wenn
ich mir das angehört das immer an ist ja
ich bin ganz nah an den bürgern sondern
seinen kindern und die kriege dieses
leid schon seit jahren immer wieder
fragt man mich kommst du mit auf demos
kannst und wird dann machen die weiß ja
wie die presse immer macht gehst du so
eine demo und schon bist du wieder
reinholen sie haben es ja vorhin gesagt
du hast dir sagt lena wenn die kinder
endlich wieder masken machen dann ist
das erste mal auf der straße ist mal
wieder aufpassen wenn ich danach mache
das war wieder nicht irgendwelchen
steigen wieder drehen komischerweise ist
das wort der moment ein bisschen weg hat
man vielleicht die merkt das gar nicht
so viele dinge wissen denn aber für mich
ist ganz klar ja einmal lügt dem glaubt
man nicht und ich habe noch nie so viele
widersprüche und behalten und auch lügen
gehört wie von lauterbach einer
bockwurst eine bockwurst hat mehr
glaubwürdigkeit als dieser minister
haben wir machen immer weiter und wer
sie ihn weiter gewähren er möchte im
mittelblock los ist jetzt etwas
überspitzt immer eine hockete stimmt
natürlich aber muss eine menge schaden
an entscheidend ist für mich erklärte um
die bürger und dieser
freiheitseinschränkung die ihr passieren
auf dem rücken vor allem der menschen
hier sind die haben gelernt damit zu
leben muss man kriegt vielleicht
französisch lernen muss ich meinen pass
abwägen da sollten wir darüber gehen
weil es geht ja immer weiter und das
einzige was sie war ein lauter bei einem
unterton immer wieder höre ist in
der 89 wir haben jetzt bessere die alten
brücken gar nicht mehr haben das ist es
vielleicht sollte dann doch gleich in
die pharma lobby gehen vielleicht will
er an seinen posten wie man ihn
vielleicht vielleicht geht ja immer so
ein ding wenn ich antrete ich weiß es
nicht aber wie lange für
freiheitsliebende politik partei macht
ihr denn eigentlich noch mit bevor er
endlich mal sagt es reicht
zumindest mit diesen politikern vor
abgaben- sie die gleiche temperatur oder
gehen das sind ganz klar bin ich ruhiger
weil ich ein bisschen älter bin aber
runde im grunde sehen wir kämpfen wir
beide ja in der gleichen richtung weit
unter wenn ich das so sehe meine letzten
beiden lauterbach nach nein wir setzen
uns weiter für die sachen ein und alles
und ich ich muss mal einen satz dazu
sagen wo sie alles beschlossen haben
alle parteien da ging es relativ schnell
mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz und
ruckzuck war das ding erledigt aber
jetzt zurück wo man was gemeint da geht
wieder nichts da schiebt einer de manna
die verantwortung zu ja und das ist
einfach nicht in ordnung alles geht
alles funktioniert wenn es in eine
richtung geht aber zurück drehen ich
habe damit nichts zu tun ich will damit
nichts zu tun haben und da muss ich
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen das hat nichts
mehr mit der realität zu tun was auf der
straße passiert was mit den menschen
passiert was mit den kindern passiert
was mit den bürgern passiert und sie
machen sich gedanken tagein tagaus das
geht immer drei vier monate fünf monate
sechs monate und nichts passiert und das
ist das dilemma was wir in deutschland
haben und das stimmt nicht mehr wie
traurig ich muss sagen ich habe sie
haben es ja so ein bisschen angesprochen
mittlerweile hohen respekt ich war am
anfang ja auch ich war für die
impfpflicht und sowas das habe ich dann
alles nicht alles aber ich hab es dann
revidiert dann auch in deutsch sowie der
war am anfang mehr dafür und so stimmt
aber ich habe hohen respekt vor den
menschen die wirklich demonstrieren ich
war letztens in münchen sagt mal
tatsächlich im café und auf einmal war
ich wusste nicht haben also ein
demonstrationszug dann und es waren
viele viele menschen und das waren ganz
eine frau kam zu mir gesagt ich bin
heute hier zum ersten mal in meiner mit
53 jahre alt sagt ich bin 53 ich bin zum
ersten mal bei einer demo dabei ich
arbeite im medizinischen bereich das ist
mir wichtig und hat es mir erklärt war
und so ist das und viele viele menschen
sind da obwohl sie stigmatisiert werden
sie wurden im letzten winter von der
polizei zum teil davon abgehalten zu
demonstrieren als eben unter corona
schutzmaßnahmen die demos und
ansammlungen verboten wurden sie werden
jetzt stigmatisiert wie jeder der sie
glücklicherweise ging gegen die
steigenden öl- gas- und ölpreise wenden
wird als rechte bande wurde die stieg
man sieht als querdenker und gehen
trotzdem demonstrieren und das sind halt
zum großen großen teil wirklich besorgte
menschen besorgt er in der lobby experte
mal sagen was da eigentlich hinter
stehen mobbing ist ein problem der
gesellschaft nicht der schulen und was
da passiert diese vorangetriebene
spaltung das ist gezielt das ist auch
mittel in der politischen seit jahren
gewesen in dem moment es ist immer eine
gruppendynamik ein gruppenzwang wenn man
anfängt leute und in deutschland immer
der gefährlicher die missstände
anspricht als der die missstände macht
und zu verantworten hat in dem moment
war mit dem finger auf andere zeit und
sie in eine bestimmte ecke drückt oder
für etwas schuldig spricht dann machen
einige mit manche sind davon überzeugt
und manche auch wir müssen da glaub ich
mitmachen und dann ist es eine form des
mobbings mobbing bedeutet übrigens aus
glänzender andere ausschließen und
spalten und das war ein willkommenes
mittel dieser politik diese menschen zu
machen und besonders wenn prominente den
mund aufgemacht hat hat man gleich drauf
gehauen hat es bei chemisch gesehen dass
ein recht über seinen körper zu
bestimmen nein denn wohl da ein exempel
statuiert dass alle anderen promis
seinen mund halten bei mir weitaus so
ich habe gesagt ich hatte eine sendung
bei einem sender ja dann hat man mich
angerufen sagt kasten wo wir strahlen
kann seine sendung aus könntest du ja
extra ubisoft ich werde jetzt gar nichts
sagen die drei wochen wo die sendung
läuft nee wir wollten eigentlich das
tuten statement gibst du dich davon
distanziert habe ich gesagt mach bitte
welcher sein er war das dann herrscht
also rtl 2 mit meiner sendung war er
dann auf einmal weg und dann gesagt
hätte ich einen scheißdreck tun ist
natürlich meine eigene werte verraten
dann stammt die sendung eines mir bist
mir vorkommt worauf sein haben sie die
seit jahren noch nicht weg gewesen ist
als so scheiß auf rtl2 aber scheiß mich
auf unsere kinder unsere bürger ihr habe
ich doch nicht zum verräter für meine
eigenen ideen für meine eigenen werte
nur für beschissen sender oder wegen so
einer sendung mail und chat ist der
unterschied weil der charakter zeigt
sich und viele promis schweigen weil sie
gesehen habe anderen waren viele geräte
mit viel kannst du hast vollkommen recht
ich würde nicht öffentlich sagen weil
man genau weil man angst hat wirtschaft
zu werden weil man angst ausgegrenzt zu
werden das wundert wenn die scheiße
wieder von vorne anfängt
dann werdet ihr diesmal merken dass es
nicht so läuft der stadt großen respekt
dass sie auf ihre sendung verzichte
scheißlauf geht um kinder